I thought my supplements were expensive at $400 a month, but a high dose of vitamin C
infusion is $500. Okay, so this is pretty high for a cost of a vitamin C infusion. Usually,
it's about $150. But in some areas, it's the market, it's whatever the market proves.
Even though you recommended this for me, isn't worth it. So if it, if, if cost is an issue,
you don't have to do this. So a cost is an issue. Just go with either, as long as just regular oral
vitamin C isn't bothering your stomach, you could do that. But you just want to get about
three grams a day. If you could do liposomal, which is a little bit more expensive than just
oral capsules of vitamin C, you could probably get by with maybe two grams a day of that.
And that's about two teaspoons of the liposomal that we have. It's still more expensive than
the capsules, but it's way less expensive than a $500 infusion. This is the highest price vitamin C
infusion that anybody's ever shared with us at least. So yeah, if this was cost prohibitive,
just go with the liposomal or just the oral capsules. That should be fine.